as kevin told you the general was filmed
in 1926 in cottage grove oregon
and i'm going to just show you a little
bit about how they made the film while
they were there
now this one photo
kind of explains
much of how they filmed the the moving
cottage grove it turned out that just
east of town there was a set of parallel
train tracks that ran for about a half a
mile and so what they did is they had
buster and the actors travel along one
track and then the camera traveled along
on the parallel track to the north
and so all the traveling shots that you
see were filmed this way
i love this photo because
it also formed the background for the
the photo that buster gave annabelle
now another feature that you'll see in
the background is this is hanson butte
um
and this is how it looks today
and i point that out because we'll be
seeing a lot of hanson butte in just a
moment
now i said most of the general was
filmed in cottage grove most of the
journal was filmed very close to town
and so while it was obviously a very
strenuous shoot with all the stunts and
whatever
and they also had to travel over 800
miles to get from hollywood to cottage
grove once they got to cottage grove a
lot of it was actually fairly convenient
to shoot
so this is
this is the cottage grove hotel it was
on main street
and uh this is where buster and most of
the crew stayed
during the filming
and here's how it looks today
cottage grove
at cottage grove as a tourist attraction
has several murals and so they pay
tribute to buster here and as randy
mentioned there's a there's a plaque
commemorating buster shooting the film
just on the front steps of the hotel
now as you'll see
the set for marietta georgia
was was filmed and was built just about
three blocks from the hotel where
everyone was staying
and in the background there's hanson
butte
now they they took that set and they
reconverted it to chattanooga tennessee
and there's hanson butte
and in all the scenes when buster's
traveling east
they filmed it here and there's hanson
butte
and in all the scenes when they're
traveling west
and i'm glad i'm giving this talk after
the film because uh
if you if i did this before i need to be
too distracted
and then the amazing scene where the
southern army retreats was filmed on the
field between the rail lines and main
street
and i just found this
just about a month ago
so that's main street in the background
and you can see as they travel along
there's some homes on main street
and thanks to
bing
maps and google earth
you can see that these two adjacent
homes
are still standing
now the other thing is the union camp
was also filmed they for the union camp
scenes the camera pointed north and for
the marietta georgia scenes the camera
pointed south but the union camp scene
was filmed was set was built at the same
spot as where the uh the marietta set
was built and in the background there i
put a box around mount david
now you'll notice in the background of
these shots there's something on the
hill
and it it kind of looks like an oil
derrick
well it turns out it was an oil derrick
a former preacher con man
came to town in 1923 and built the
citizens of cottage grove selling them
subscriptions
in this worthless oil venture
and
they finally stopped drilling a few
months before buster arrived in town and
the con man skipped town but the
worthless
oil derrick stood on the hill for years
until it finally blew over
now two of my most favorite scenes were
also filmed
a little bit further away from the hotel
but again it was
it was an easy walk the scene where
buster knocks out the railroad tie was
filmed going around this curve
and it's also
among other scenes it's also the scene
where buster throttles and then kisses
annabelle
and to give you a little perspective
um here's an aerial view of the setting
today
they took the rail line out it's now a
regional bike trail it passes underneath
an interstate highway and it leads you
to a walmart
but you can you can take a bicycle there
and ride the rails where buster filmed
just very briefly uh the scene where
he's kicked out of line
the barn in the background was on
south river road on the east side of
town
and then
when the heroes returned from home
that house is still standing on adams
and 16th street
now they did have to travel a little bit
so for the conclusion of the film
when they crashed the bridge
they filmed it near culp creek and that
was about 15 miles away from town and by
the way dorina lake
several of the the intermediate train
stations where scenes were filmed were
filmed along the rail line and they're
covered up now by dorina lake so i don't
have any photos of them but
but anyway the the conclusion of the
film was filmed
by cult
and
the
the train lay fixed in the riverbed for
years until it was finally pulled out
for world war ii for scrap so there
really isn't much of the film of the
train left
but that uh that concludes my little
comments about the general
you